ما مدى احتمالية أننا سنحتاج إلى
الاصطفاف للحصول على لقطات
معززة وماذا يحدث إذا لم يفهمها الناس
بشكل جيد ،
لذا كان أحد الأشياء التي
لاحظتها هو بعض الالتباس حول
جيم وأود أن أوضح
ذلك عندما  أنت تتحدث عن الحاجة إلى جرعة
ثالثة
في نظام اللققتين ، فأنت لا
تتحدث عن
الفعالية لأنني الآن
أعني أنك تعرف فورًا بعد 14 يومًا من الجرعة الثانية لديك
لقاح فعال للغاية وأنت
محمي للغاية  تشير اللقطة الثالثة
أو التعزيز الإضافي
إلى متانة تلك
الحماية إلى
متى تدوم ، يجب ألا تجعلها
انعكاسًا
لما إذا كان اللقاح الذي
أخذته بالفعل
فعالًا أم لا هو
فعال للغاية نحاول تحديده  لمعرفة
المدة التي تستغرقها استمرارية الإنتاج هذه ،
نعلم أنها ستنتهي
ستة أشهر على الأقل ومن المحتمل
أن تكون أطول بكثير ،
لكننا لا نعرف بالضبط كم
من الوقت تفعل الشركات ما تفعله بشكل
مناسب ويعمل المعهد الوطني للصحة
معهم
لتطوير  تهرب من هذه المعلومات لمعرفة ما
إذا كنت قد وصلت إلى نقطة
حيث تبدأ متانة الحماية
في الانخفاض قليلاً وتنخفض إلى مستوى
أدنى فأقل ، فقد تحتاج
إلى تعزيز لإبقائها ضمن هذا
النطاق الوقائي للغاية ، لذا يمكنك الحصول على طلقة واحدة أو
طلقتين  أعرف جيم لا نعرف ، أعني
أنه من المحتمل أن تكون لقطة وقد تكون واحدة
ستحتاجها
بشكل دوري مشابه لما نفعله مع
الإنفلونزا